طيب دكتور عمليه يوم واحد لتبديل مفصل
الركبه حديثنا اكثر طيب اول شيء خشونه
الركبه اتكلم عنها خشونه الركبه هو والاسف
الشديد مرض شائع موجود بشكل كبير في طبعا
له اسباب وراثيه في اسباب تتعلق بزياده
الوزن اصابات قديمه في الركبه العلاج ما
هو دائما يكون بتبديل مفصل الرقبه همم هذه
العلاج النهائي اذا كانت الخشونه جدا جدا
شديده
نقطه التبديل هنا الان همم تقليديه ان
الناس طبعا او شائع انه هذه عمليه خطيره
وصعبه ونسبه نجاحها ما هي عاليه همم طبعا
مع التقنيات الحديثه في خلال اخر 25 سنوات
صرنا نسميها عمليات اليوم الواحد وهمم
والتاهيل السريع بمعنى ان المريض يدخل
يسوي العمليه ممكن يخرج في نفس اليوم
ويجلس 24 ساعه همم في المستشفى
متابع بحيث ان المريض يمشي بعد العمليه
مباشره بعد ساعات جلوسه في المستشفى يكون
24 ساعه طبعا في مرضى يكون عندهم مشاكل
صحيه همم اخرى غير الركبه مثلا المشاكل في
القلب او غير هذا هيحتاج همم انه يجلس
اكثر من 24 ساعه
45 دقيقه صحيح مده العمليه 45 دقيقه
تقريبا همم همم ليش هذا الشيء صار انه
الحمد لله تطورت الجراحه بشكل مره كبير
وانواع المفاصل المستخدمه تطورت بشكل كبير
فخطوات العمليه صارت اقل